[Music]
the initial years in Belgium were hard
for me language was a major problem I
didn't know the native language so even
I learned a job in marketing I struggle
it is still a problem but the skill I
gained from the professional
certification program in digital
marketing have made things a lot easier
at my work after the course I got a new
job with 10 thoroughly High hey my name
is Antica udon I work in Adusa
industrial vehicle as marketing
assistant I live in Belgium with my
partner and life here is really nice
I was born and brought up in Thailand I
started my career there on a cruise ship
as a waitress during my graduation I had
opportunity to go to the USA for work
and travel I work in Florida as service
crew and store assistant my time that
helped me with my English
I came back to Thailand and start
working as an account executive with a
marketing company
in 2019 I decided to move to Belgium I
kept looking for a job for a year but it
was really hard as I am not a native
speaker I did some odd jobs here but I
knew I could do much more
I finally got a job at the company as
marketing assistant but language still
posts a big challenge for me I found it
harder to communicate to clients I was
competing against more qualified people
so I decided to update my skill and
that's why I took this course
faculty have full knowledge of subject I
found the video interesting and
self-learning makes it easier for me to
combine between job and study the course
helped me get this job and also with 10
swirly hike I feel confident now because
I am good at my job language doesn't
seems a big problem I use English at my
work and I also studied Dutch and samish
in my free time I like to play with my
dolls this is life that I have created
for myself and I am content personally
and professionally sure it was full of
struggles but my Hunger to learn kept me
going
[Music]